♪ ♪ ♪
- À Oka, les élections
municipales du 7 novembre
portent beaucoup sur
l'enjeu de la sécurité.
Le maire sortant n'en démord
pas. Le territoire voisin
de Kanesatake est, selon lui,
contrôlé par le crime organisé.
PASCAL QUEVILLON, maire sortant
d'Oka, candidat à la mairie
- On voit depuis plusieurs moisr
le territoire ici, passer
à travers Oka, des membres
de gangs de rue. Et ce qui
les attire ici, on sait
c'est quoi. C'est les caba
qui vendent du cannabis.
opposante du parti
Unité citoyenne, Julie Tremblay-
Cloutier, fait aussi notamment
campagne sur la question de
la sécurité, même si elle admet
n'avoir aucun contrôle sur
ce qui se passe à Kanesatake.
JULIE TREMBLAY-CLOUTIER, cand. à
la mairie d'Oka, Unité citoyenne
- C'est clair qu'on voit
bien des gens qui arrivent
tes sortes de milieux...
qui viennent consommer ici
et que, souvent, ces milieux-là
aussi sont propices
à toutes sortes d'autres
activités illicites.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le 13 juin 2021,
une grosse fête a eu lieu dans
le stationnement de la boutique
de cannabis Le Green Room,
où les mesures sanitaires
n'étaispectées.spectées.spectée.
Deux semaines plus tard,
le chef de gang Arsène Mompoint
était assassiné alors
qu'il était attablé sur
une terrasse du
Depuis l'incident, la terrasse
du Green Room est fermée demanie
fête n'est autorisée.
Victo
le grand chef de Kanesatake
au mois d'août dernier.
Il rejette les allégations
de Pascal Quevillon selon
lesquelles sa communauté serait
contrôlée par le crime organisé.
Depuis 2004, aucune force
policière autochtone n'estte à .
Depuis, la Sûreté du Québec
est responsable de la sécurité
sur le territoire mohawk.
Une porte-parole de la SQ
nous indique collaborer
ous les citoyens
et organismes de Kanesatake.
Mais comme c'est
le cas ailleurs au Québec,
les policiers vont parfois
rencontrer des individus
qui sont réfractaires à leur
présence sur le territoire.
Propriétaire de la boutique
de cannabis Le Diable vert,
Clifton Ariwakehte Nicholas
a combattu la Sûreté du Québec
durant la crise d'Oka en 1
- Vous êtes d'accord qu'il y a
quand même un problème desécurie
et même dans la communauté?
CLIFTON ARIWAKEHTE NICHOLAS,
propriétaire, Diable vert
- Il n'y a aucun doute,
mais la sécurité
de la Sûreté du Québec,
c'est pas une difficulté
pour nous autres. On se sent
plus menacés qu'en sécurité
avec eux autres.
- Selon Pascal Quevillon, c'est
aux gouvernements provincial
et fédéral d'intervenir.
- Nos deux paliers de
gouvernement ferment les yeux,
t'sais, on les entendait parler
au fédéral, dans leur campagne
électorale, l'eau potable,
les communautés autochtones,
ils étaient sensibles à ce qui
se passait dans les communautés
autochtones, mais oui, l'eau
potable, c'est important,
mais que le crime organisé
ait pris le contrôle
des territoires autochtones
aux dépens de la communauté,
c'est très un sécurisant
pour la communauté.
- Julie Tremblay-Cloutier
avance vouloir collaborer avec
les autorités mohawks voisines.
- Le territoire est
un territoire non surveillé,
où il y a aucune force
coercitive qui s'implique,
donc c'est clair que le crime
organisé le perçoit comme
une facilité et un endroit
où ils peuvent foisonner.
Donc, pour moi, c'est clair
qu'une partie de la solution
passe par des forces
de sécurité, mais c'est
au conseil de bande et
aux citoyens de Kanesatake
de trouver les meilleures
solutions pour eux.
- Pour Clifton Ariwakehte
Nicholas, la solution
à l'insécurité doit
passer par le dialogue.
- Content d'une sécurité
dans cette communauté, content
d'une différence par les forces
extérieures. On doit parler
ensemble, entre nous autres,
ici avant, puis on doit faire...
une réconciliation avec
le village d'Oka.
- Une réconciliation
qui serait bienvenue pour
améliorer le sentiment de
sécurité chez les allochtones
comme